you know Altman said about Robert the
last time you saw me that he's the
greatest actor of his generation and
there is no question you know that
Robert is the greatest actor of his
generation and what he's done over these
last 10 years that the performance and
endgame is a profound performance that
deeply moved people around the world on
a scale that we I think you've never
seen before so that doesn't deserve a
nomination I don't know what does it's
it's basically a process of just
stepping through the narrative and
figuring out where these characters are
taking us in the specific film where
what journey they've been on since their
beginnings in the MCU and how do we sort
of pay off those arcs and the most
surprising and satisfying ways and if I
think that's how we discover these
various deaths as we were crap and well
the way we look at its death its
ennobling and you know when you're a
hero your job is to sacrifice yourself
for the greater good no matter what one
of the great creative upsides of endgame
for Joe and I was like every single
Marvel movie we've always been thinking
about the future thinking about the
future meaning where do these stories go
where did these characters go when we
did endgame we didn't think about the
future at all like our job was simply to
come up with the the most satisfying
conclusion we could and so we kind of
just laid it there it was Robert's son
who used to say that was exactly and Joe
and I have a highly collaborative
process we work as a team we love
working with actors so and Robert is one
of those actors who he's as a brilliant
story mind and he has a capacity as a
filmmaker that goes beyond just acting
so we spend a lot of time talking with
him about the character about the story
and I think was just in one of those
conversations he kind of randomly
brought it up and as soon as he said it
we're like well it's gonna have to be
stuck it's amazing and then I don't
think we came up with the idea to use it
later to wrap around the film but he's a
hologram till it we're in post I think
yeah
he was actually a perfect way to
camouflage a funeral because people
dress very similarly for both things so
in the costume department when the
actors were getting fit for formal book
dark clothes it could plausibly be for a
wedding and a gathering of that many
characters together in one place could
plausibly be for a wedding so it just
seemed like the perfect camouflage for
the deal
yeah I mean look when you're trying to
pull that big of a cast together those
agents and managers hair and makeup
there's a massive collection people that
could to give something away so
unfortunately you have to cool them
they're under false pretenses and then
when they're there they're all actors
you say listen here's what's really
going on and they say that's sad okay we
got it
there we go action the whole idea of
killing Thanos that early in the film
sort of came out of just story sessions
and now that he was dead where would we
go with the storytelling this
opportunity to sort of jump into the in
- everybody's futures and see five years
down the road how this is weighing on
them how the new reality that sounds
this great is weighing on them it just
seemed all very exciting on a
storytelling one Fargo season one had an
incredible time generally at the end of
the season was there an settling in a
great way because I went I have no idea
what's going now and I think that really
inspired the time jumped in this movie
we wanted to do something that unsettled
the audience and in that moment when
you're watching it go I have no idea
we're always looking for ways to keep
these characters fresh and surprising to
audiences so you know when you jump five
years forward it's like where are they
at what have they been doing for the
past five years it's like you're re
you're ream eating them again in a new
form when we were prepping the film and
developing the film is certainly one of
our favorite things that we were doing
in the movie you know our sort of
creative processes like how do we how do
we subvert things how do we find ways to
twist things and run against
expectations and the ability to take
this God who physically looks like a God
to in terms of human beauty and then
sort of subvert that and turn that into
something real and relatable and
vulnerable and that was coming from a
source of inner pain and that's what
we're always looking for is the humanity
these characters and then it seemed like
a very powerful way to access their
humanity it is very funny certainly on
one level but it's also very emotional
and it has an amazing human texture to
it did you started asking logical
questions because it could have been
either of them they're both heroes and
they were both sacrificed their life and
a heartbeat
what do you go okay they're gonna fight
each other it's for the right to jump
off of a cliff to kill themselves who's
gonna win in a fight well Black Widow is
always gonna win in a fight because we
know from Avengers she's a better
fighter and ultimately - it felt very
satisfying just for her are you really
that really what's guiding us is the
character arcs you know where do we want
to take these characters in the
storytelling and I think that's what
drove that choice which is Black Widow
began as an orphan she was a part of a
surrogate family that she didn't feel
connected to and was using her she had
the good fortune of discovering the
Avengers
Hawkeye sort of sparing her life and
bringing her into the Avengers and she
found a new family and that family
became very important to her and she
dedicated herself to preserving that
family and holding it together and
that's what she's doing an end game and
it's like we just felt like that was the
most satisfying end of her arc that she
would be willing in order to maintain
this family that she loves she has to
actually sacrifice herself for that that
seemed very noble we thought seriously
about it because of the history with the
comics but it was pretty clear in the
MCU which way we were gonna go I mean
Sam had such a strong connection with
the cab you know their their backgrounds
of military backgrounds their sort of a
their humility their ability to focus on
this service they felt very connected on
that level it felt like he could trust
Sam even though he and Bucky are best
friends felt like you know he could also
really trust Sam
right that's a good question but that
has a magnetic question we may have
started that yeah we we we subscribe to
that there
okay so or we like Joe said we yeah yeah
I mean that may have even ordered region
eight I mean that's the I mean I guess I
was a conspiracy theory if it if you say
directors and writers in in that's candy
I know I think that if we get reaching
that point in in the universe where like
narrative now belongs to everyone I mean
you can go back and see cap actually
move there was movement there you know
nobody else can do that
we knew that he's gonna will the hammer
we just wanted to figure out the best
way to reveal it yeah and there was a
bunch of different constructions there
there was one though he actually could
see him picking it up there's one where
it's just a hammer and we liked hiding
the ball on it and found it was a little
bit more dramatic to reveal them in the
moment when the hammer came back to him
we did that the kenwood push into him
yeah battles take a long time it takes
honestly years that take you know but we
could spend two years trying to figure
out one of those battle sequences and a
lot of times we get a good sense of what
we want it to be in a shape of it and
then we mold it some more in the Edit
room and we're using storyboards and
pre-visualization to you know illustrate
what that is we get music in it starts
to change it and then what's great about
Marvel is they're very iterative and I
think this is really the secret sauce of
what movies are so good as they continue
to evolve the film even in post and the
famous reshoots that Marvel does you
always have the opportunity to make it
better and so we'll get a shape of what
the battle is and then come up with new
ideas come up with new previz and then
we'll go out and shoot the elements to
make it work the way that we want it to
work
really hard to say like sometimes you
have to go shot by shot to describe it
because it change sometimes there's two
versions of something and sometimes will
rely on one version for certain shots
and another version for the other shot
but their quantum suits that they travel
back in time and those were entirely CG
Thoreau has CG elements too sometimes
his arms Chiclets and its cape yeah
spider-man's CG Iron Man and war machine
yeah
winter soldiers arm yeah as a
combination is our house when they're
all charging we only had certain members
of the cast of that anyone was actually
physically running on the ground who's
not CG was there any was in the air was
not there you know those are elements
that will put put in later so he had the
largest collection we had was for Tony's
funeral largest collection of a cache
and when cap catches the hammer and says
Avengers Assemble yeah right now that
big shot they were all there for that
yeah that's the most special part of it
for our reason we make these movies are
for the fans because we want to give
them the same experiences that we had
growing up and you know the same
emotional connection to material that we
felt when we saw Indiana Jones or Star
Wars to try the Jedi impress Rick's back
and we actually snuck into a theater
opening night in Westwood and it was an
amazing experience as a filmmaker you
rarely get something where people
respond that dramatically that intensely
with that much localization just
something that you do and that was
special in a in a movie theater am I at
a rock concert you know that's just like
it's so rare that a theater sounds like
that it's really thought that we're
gonna have to call the paramedics for
the poor kid behind us at the Tony Stark
moment he was hyperventilating and you
know
you